oh dania um i'm i'm i'm in a very dire
situation
if i don't hit 2500
bullet in the next 16 days i have to
shave my hair
um it wouldn't it wouldn't be a good
look i really like my hair
and uh right now my rating is is 23.66
i will say i have uh flirted with 24.80
off stream and that was maybe last week
so it is it is all hope is not lost but
uh we're we're really gonna need the
assist here
i will do my absolute best um you have
my word and i'll try to make time we can
do
several sessions
[Laughter]
i think you've got a good shot at i mean
especially since you were 24 80.
and are you do you usually hover or have
you hovered around
the high 2300s um on stream
or are you really up and down on stream
my floor is
usually 2400 when i fall under 2400 i
get so tilted that i
go towards 23.50 once i hit 2400 i can
go between the 40s to the 60s on
on stream i got you perfect yeah
[Music]
um let me lay out a little bit i put
some thought into some of the things
that we can do
maybe i can share with you sort of a
broad picture of some of the stuff that
perhaps we can do and maybe you can add
your input as well as
your general thoughts on sort of your
strengths and weaknesses
bullet bullet-wise so i've never done a
bullet session so forgive me for
you know anything that doesn't work out
um we can do it
i have nothing but gratitude for you
being here to help us i appreciate that
no it's a lot of fun for me and i'm i'm
embracing the challenge so
danielle we can't lose the hair i know i
got the message
i will be okay i will pull pull out
every stop so i will okay
hold no prisoners crook no trespass okay
so um i guess we can separate this into
two things we there's
sort of what i would call technique or
mechanics um
and there's a bunch of stuff we can
discuss about um
you know about pre-moving and sort of
what your openings look like in bullet
and stuff like adding a little bit of a
dirty component to your play
usually but sometimes i honestly i think
you could get dirtier so i'm looking for
the tips
right and i'm sure that most of the
stuff you're already implementing
um but you know there's a lot of that to
talk through so we'll incorporate that
into the training overall and in terms
of the actual practice in terms of the
actual drills
to work on work on your speed and work
on your technique
we basically play odds games where like
i blunder my queen on on move two
um and you have 30 seconds to beat me um
so we
we basically play 30 seconds on odds
chess
um or one minute odds chess so that's
that's a basic
um way i think of working on your
technique and working on your speed
perfect oh you can start the game
awesome wait wait i'm going to give you
30 seconds because i want you to play
like my phone oh yeah exactly
i think that'll that correction will
approximate
the level that you play against
i gave you 20 perfect that that works
see these are the kinds of positions
that i i don't know how to play right
okay i reside that was a great game
alexander i i think you're gonna have no
trouble with
hitting 2500. i have nothing left to
teach you beautiful win 15 moves
whoa just inconclusive thanks for the 3
000.
yeah so so the opening went astray thank
you
so do you want to go over each game
individual do you want to play like a
like
five or six games and then go over all
together what do you prefer um
what do you think is faster because it
you could test all my st we could do
something where you test all of my
systems
you see where the problems are and then
we do it go perfect that's
exactly what i had in mind okay perfect
uh
all right i'm gonna set it now people in
the chat are like he let her win you
don't say
you don't say what no well i guess
i'll play a better better bullet player
you know
i mean if i can survive over 15 minutes
against you i consider that a great
success
perfect okay all right uh
okay just play fast as if yeah i'll play
i'll play very fast
dude i hate the same-ish also um i used
to play the c5 line i don't play it
anymore so i i go for these kinds of
systems and everything yeah this is
you know this can unfortunately get you
mated pretty fast
and i mean this is okay for black but
it's super risky because you see your g
files close and you have no attack going
against me
but uh you want a pawn so i think that's
reason enough for me to resign i
yeah i i didn't want to i think i think
i nailed it
right okay let's try the fiance
oh shoot shoot i don't play this line i
play d5
oh you played your five against fan cam
you want to go d5 now and i'll waste a
move sometimes i play too quickly and if
this was a
or an actual bullet game i would panic
and paint right into this
as you can tell my openings are actually
europeans are amazing
it's just you're basically winning out
of everything you are winning do you
think i could write an opening book
donya would you maybe
i'm surprised you haven't done that yet
yeah it was actually on my to-do list
um okay wait let's try that again all
right
wait don't don't accept yeah i want to
accept them okay go ahead
three zeros you by the way
oh it's interesting because when you
play it like this i actually don't play
my line correctly
oh yeah yeah
interesting okay so you play early queen
h5
that's a joke
okay you're not gonna adopt me though i
i i need to be nice you're you're a
coach you know
okay wait i try the fan kiddo again i'll
play g3 earlier this and that's how most
people who play it i almost moused this
oh
yeah so this is so so you trick me when
you play it like this and i don't
actually play d5 no you're right so
do you play the grunfeld against this i
don't it's only if you play d4 later
that i'll play d5 so
okay for bullet i think that that sounds
a little bit too complicated
it is i mean if you want just to play
stick with the king's indian that would
be the best option
um i should play it with d6
okay i'll let you keep testing lines all
right let me think about what i want to
play so we got that we got that
you got an ipd7 okay let's do i will
actually look up what people play
against you as well after i finish
testing your system that is
way too nice i you i don't deserve that
you got this in the bag so i'm just
yeah i took your pond on you oh i guess
you actually have a good position here
so thank you this is the first one i'm
not gonna lie it's the first
time four pawns attack you're good
against the four pawns attack
thank you thank you all right so
oh whoops i'm black yeah okay all aboard
all right again now careful about
removing g6 because i'm going to try to
trick you
yeah dirty
i thought i thought i was wrong
i was wrong have you faced knight c3
i got so excited i'm sorry um
oh you thought that's the dirty move i
was going to play ah
i'm sorry i didn't understand i thought
you're gonna try to
fong me um i've graduated from that to
other other dirty tricks
i i believe it that's kind of like your
your first one you know
it's a write-up passage yeah exactly
okay good good i mean
reasonable
[Laughter]
okay it's like when you said you have a
good chance to not be
bald it's like that's not what a girl
wants to hear ever
i want to be certain i'm not going to be
evolving c6 was the winning move there
yep
was it actually no oh sorry i was i was
gonna ask if you thought it was actually
it probably was it's decent c6 d5 um
but we definitely we're gonna work on
the king's indian because i
my philosophy is that openings might be
playing a much bigger role
i think they're actually playing a huge
role in bullet because they make me lose
so much time and i guess yeah it's not
an intuitive thing people
like people will think that's weird but
i'm actually getting the sense
that when you get your type of position
and i know that from our all of our odds
matches
you can play 2600 strength easily
but these passive when you get your type
of position
oh you wanna okay i see what you're
doing there i see what you're doing
you're good you're good you're good but
i i truly believe that i think when you
there there's but these passive
positions with no plan i can see what
you're saying it's uh
you burn a ton of clock and then even if
you climb out of it in the end you're
just very low on time
exactly exactly okay let me let me try
one more for now
and then and then i will look up uh what
people actually play against you with
the greatest frequency
and we'll go from the order of that
okay let's go just like some h3 stuff
let's see how you just
general ideas
that's the blender i often do still
that's actually
decent for black
okay whoops i've learned my queen there
so i'm gonna resign
yeah okay okay um so
that definitely gives me a a good
sampling if you just give me one second
i'm going to check uh on this opening
tree site what people actually
play against you most frequently okay
it's not a bride play the king's indian
so it's it's it
it's quite helpful for me to to review
these concepts i know it's not and
you're doing me a huge favor
and i appreciate you trying to i know
you do
it is a pleasure so okay so e4 d6
so you play ipd7 to avoid the exchange
variation right yeah because the
exchange variation is a pain in bullet
it's just not worth it
i completely agree and has anyone played
e5 against you here
no no nobody knows e5 okay nobody does
it
so it's not a good move and play knight
g4
i uh yeah just give me one second i'm
pulling up some i have some chest bass
notes here
and i'm gonna fire up the engine in case
we need to check something
so e5 yeah so e5
you one moment you take and go knight g4
and the only thing white can try is like
e6
you just take it and if they go here
then you have
a very simple move uh knight takes f2
and you're winning everything they're
you beat them to the punch basically
okay perfect
yeah uh so that's not a problem so
castle's e5
um so so castles e5 um
yeah and then i play e oh sorry c5
actually i'll just let you control it
sorry sure no problem so so d5 is
actually not the best move
um but it's i i know that it's the most
commonly played it's extremely annoying
it's the main line i really struggle
with bishop e3
it's the best yeah bishop b3 is the best
line yeah um so let's start with bishop
e3 now because bishop e3 my mind just
gets confused
absolutely so i'll show you like i'll
present an idea and
by all means you can say no um it's you
know i want to make sure that you're
comfortable
with the lines that you play so he takes
d4 which you played against me
this is a structure that i have a lot of
experience in you can play this kind of
structure successfully
and i like the structure when white
makes certain concessions beforehand
but here white basically has an ideal
setup so
i assume you get the structure pretty
frequently and you're sort of
floundering around here
yep very much flounder so at some point
i'll show you the tricks
in this structure but a move that
actually is
quite good in this position is to start
with rookie a
i used to play this as my full-time line
oh wow
it looks bad it it actually it looks
like he's going to play d5
well yeah and here there's a rerouting
of your pieces which
again the good thing about it is that
you can almost play it automatically
it makes it hard for white to attack and
i've won a couple of classical games
here
you start with the move knight h5 now
your basic point this is very rare in
the king's indian is you're going to get
your bishop to e7
your knight to g7 and then you're gonna
play f5 quickly
so um normally normally one second let
me
just make sure i'm telling you the truth
yeah are you live dania is someone
paying you to get me bald
exactly total sabotage so no knight h5
is is the move and um
almost everybody here with white plays
g3 in response
now um if and i don't know how your
opponents
generally play these types of positions
but if they don't play g3
you're going to play knight f4 and
you're going to
try to eliminate the bishop and quickly
play your opponents instead of bad
opponents
i i i think actually most people here
would not know to play g3 or maybe they
would
yeah and and once you start playing this
it's not like this is her last session
we'll see
what people end up playing and we will
look accordingly so
uh one good idea is to meet b4 with the
move a5
you generally want to test people now
the more of this tension
that you create in bullet the better
this is a source of tension that you
control why
because if they take on a5 and you
ignore this
not a problem it's okay what i mean to
say is if you forget to take on a5
because you've pre-moved that's okay
if you take on b4 and they've pre-moved
they lose a knight
yeah so i would define this as a
pressure point that you control
um that's why these moves are really
good time pressures in terms of bullet
and time pressure
i mean i'll try to give you like not all
of the moves i'm about to say are
necessarily
strictly speaking the best although this
one is and now you go knight f4 now if
he takes this is always going to be good
for you even if you drop this pawn
yeah i remember this from the white side
how are you going to follow up with
black like queen d2
um let's see
i'm very tempted to push g5 that's a
good idea to protect it but
to go for the center or 95 95 is i would
say even better
and then you're you have a beautiful
square here you're much much better
okay so you know and otherwise your goal
is to take on e2 and quickly go f5 now
once you go f5 then you're go knight f6
and you're good
um yeah my guess is probably not too
many people will play g3
if they do you go bishop f8 oh my god
this but this is so easy to remember
it is and the point of this is that you
make it harder in the long run for white
to play c5
so the main line goes 91 knight g7 um
and i've had
a couple of classical games that went
this way bishop e7
and then you're ready to play f5 knight
f6 and you know boris galphon lost the
game
classical game here with white this is a
pretty dangerous system
uh so so black is going for queen side
stuff here and black is going for the
usual
b4 c5 right white usually yeah white
goes before
some of the time and you go f5 and your
next move
almost regardless of what white is going
to do is going to be knight f6
okay and um one second you can also
start with f5 then play bishop b7 it
doesn't really matter so queen d2 is the
main move here by the way
instead of b4 if they play b4 ah
okay so if b4 sorry if f3 here
then you want to go bishop g5 and you
know that in the king's indian it's a
good idea to trade dark square bishops
and keep light square bishops right
yes so you know this is the bishop the
one that i've highlighted that you want
to keep so bishop g5 here
because this is the one you use on sax
sometimes and you have the exact attack
whereas the other one is just blocked
off yep
precisely so if they take you take then
you go knight f6 f4 and you just blast
through on the king side this other
knight can go into h5 by the way
okay so that's um
that's a very basic rundown of of the d5
line
i know now i'm gonna save the pgn at the
end so just don't delete any variation
no of course of course
now white can also stall with queen c2
or take on e5 do you anticipate people
doing that
um stalling with queen d2 i mean
queen c2 queen c2 no queen c2 is not a
bullet move i think
taking on e5 or pushing d5 okay so let's
look at d
let's look at d takes e5 okay so d takes
c5
um d takes e5 is the harder one for me
to play d5 a5
is not so bad right that makes sense so
here you're gonna
you're gonna blast people because the
bottom line is
what is black's ultimate plane you want
to unfurl your pieces so you want to
take this square under control
how do you do that uh knight b6 or c6 c6
usually you want to do it with pawns and
then you have all of these weak squares
in white's camp
that you want to occupy with your pieces
you want to do it methodically so what
is y going to do here
i mean queen c2 is reasonable h3 um it
doesn't actually really matter you're
going to play c6
then you're going to bring the queen to
e7 um a lot of people put their queen on
c7
i think it's better to put it on e7 why
that's actually
interesting because i yeah i'm always
trying to decide between these two
because because queen e7 brings the c5
score under control which makes possible
to move an ic5
got it okay so queen e7 and it's just a
little bit more energetic so
let's say c6 or kd1 queen queen e7 and
also you you are discouraging white from
playing c5 and now
you're going to have two ways of dealing
with this knight the ultimate setup is
to go either knight fade or knight c5
sorry then go bishop g4 traded for
white's knight
and do you see where this is leading up
to what is your ultimate goal um
so you're trying to take on f three well
then why would you do that
what square are you softening up for
that knight to occupy potentially
d4 yeah exactly yeah so you're gonna go
knight f8 bishop g4
take and then go 96 move the other
knight over and then go knight t4
all it sounds like it's a million moves
but the reality is
you can be flexible and white doesn't
have a very good plan here
it's a very straightforward plan so so
in this position
um let's say white plays something like
h3
okay do you play knight f8 yeah you can
play knight f8 or knight c5
i like knight f8 okay um it's just that
knight
so now you don't have this plan anymore
right you don't have this plan but you
have a different plan you can go knight
h5
knight e6 and then put one knight on f4
and you know sort of eye the d4s where
they're gonna end up doing something
that's gonna allow you
in my experience to put a knight on on
either d4 or f4
it's very hard for white to play this
kind of position right so
basically with black you're deciding
between the d4 and c4 square
um and then in this position since g4
wasn't allowed for your bishop that's
why you're just rerouting your knight
anyway to f4
yeah you don't want to push too many
pawns by the game exactly and you don't
you also can go
with the old traditional idea of knight
h5 f5 do you go for f5 pushes in this
kind of position sometimes not in bullet
though i mean that's more of a classical
thing
i would refrain from it until you've
deployed all of your pieces to the
proper squares now in terms of the
bishop
there's nothing wrong with b6 bishop b7
it's not glamorous but
it's fine and remember also at some
point the idea of c5 and knight t4
be careful about white putting the
knight on d5 but
that's sort of a thing you'll have to
weigh on the spot
okay so b6
bishop b7 96 knight h5 okay that makes
sense
yup and knight f4 and then you can start
considering various sacrifices on g2 and
h3
uh and and stuff like that we can also
play some games with colors reverse like
i take black in a position like this and
demonstrate some of the ways to put
pressure and bullet we'll do that at
some point
okay so that makes sense from a general
point of view
yeah that makes sense so the key memory
marker is this mover key you don't take
on d4 now rookie threatens
ed and knight takes c4 so if they screw
around they go rookie one
some people do that in both they just
like subconsciously copy you just take
in 94.
yeah yeah play ed knight e4 and
just one one clarification that if they
give you a check on d4
just go back to f6 and okay you're solid
yeah no yeah and then you want to go
knight c5 get your bishop out
your aquapon for no compensation okay
so that's i mean and this line once you
get your feet under you is going to be
is going to serve you very well i think
now
last sort of mainline king's indian
thing um before we move on
i know that most people aren't going to
play quincy too but i do want to show
you
how to play this position really quickly
if that sounds good to you
in case it sounds great it sounds great
i've had this for
uh forever so night so first of all
easy and then f3 i'm guessing yes now
you
always want to follow this move up so
you don't want to go a5
most of okay see because this is my this
is a habit that i would just push
immediately i mean you can but i like i
like going c6
interesting and you're not afraid of b4
no
because i'm going to go knight e6 i
actually the point of this system of the
black is to make them overextend
themselves particularly in bullet you
want undefended pieces
in as high of a quantity as possible
okay so try to play white here try to
make a couple of moves
all right and i'm gonna walk you through
you taking the bishop yeah you're taking
with the bishop so i don't want to do
that
um so i guess if i'm white here i'm
going to play it a little slowly
okay so now i'm going to play this move
knight h5 which sets up a bunch of
tricks
um of varying types
now one thing i want to clear up you can
play a5 like
at some point i'm not saying you never
make that move but what i'm telling you
is that b4 is not something to
truly be afraid of in most cases yeah
right
now here's and if they take on e6 a lot
of people will see the move c5 and oh
you know they'll think they're winning
the pawn but they miss the forest for
the trees you're already better with
black
how would you play here
how would i play here if they push c5
let's see
so what do we have going on so g takes
c5 is an option my knight is looking
towards the f4 square it doesn't really
do anything we have a pin on the knight
which makes
d5 slightly interesting yeah um
as soon as something's slightly yeah and
that's reason enough to play the bullet
so
you're relying so heavily on your
intuition when you see stuff like this
you do it immediately okay d5 ed
and uh you know bishop takes d5 is very
good here to rip open the e file and
everything is just falling apart for
white
okay um and and this position can happen
i mean this is the kind of thing if
white just slow plays it how you should
go for it right
with knight c5 c6 96 knight h5 because
this is a very common idea
yeah some people won't play b4 though
and if they don't play b4 nothing
changes
like if they go rook d1 you want to put
your queen again on e7
not on c7 on e7 and then you want to
play knight h5
now one last idea is once you play
knight h i'm making a random move away
in this position you notice that the
bishop on e3 is unprotected
which opens up the possibility for what
move um
okay well d5 and f5 come to mind and
which one seems less
risky more kings indian e f5 seems like
the natural one
and it is because you're going to go f5
fe or f5 f4
and then you're going to put your bishop
on e5 you've got a great position okay
the key is to play very actively in
these structures and that's another
reason why you want your queen 97 not
just c5 but because of the semi-open e
file
exactly the queen is just better placed
there overall
okay and that's the bottom line in these
structures
um so so this is what you play against
the bishop e3 line just
rookie eight is the key move here rookie
it is the chemo i've been taking on d4
i'm so no more taking and i i just wait
for white to say what happens if if
white keeps the tension that's what we
just looked at right right
rookie eight and then queen c2 yeah so
rookie queen c2
now now i would take on d4 so here's you
taking on d4 too quickly is not such a
big problem
because you do get the structure in an
improved version
it's included the moves rookie queen c2
which is good for black
and now continue with the typical moves
knight c5 knight e6 is what we do
not immediately you don't want to play
them unless they played beef but i want
to prompt them
players so if it's uncomfortable for you
to allow before you could play a5 here
like i have no problem with that
no no i'll allow it i played c6 is the
line you go for here so let's say i go
here
um so queen e7 just move out of the way
that's a good move
okay let's say i go rook fe1 hey maybe
just
prepare with my bingo okay let me go
bishop f1
okay um so i'm not going to go f5
because now you have your rook on e1
i don't want to go knight e6 just yet so
maybe just develop unless
good move no that's a good move and one
way you could deal with this is go
bishop e5
oh and then quickly go queen h4 okay
this place seems a little bit sharper
and might be scary in bullet
so maybe bishop e5 is a better bullet
though yes and you can you can go 96 on
your own volition to get the knight over
to f4 to put pressure on their knight
this also defends the d6 spawn
okay queen h4 ideas become possible
people you know 24 2500
they're likely to freak out here and do
something irrational after
bishop e5 and queen h4 i think so i mean
i've won just countless bullet games
with this
setup in these kinds of positions
because they just worry okay now i like
it i like it so bishop
right and then i guess you just played
bishop f2 right
bishop f2 and now it would be a good
time actually to step back to e6 and put
pressure on the knight
so there is a moment where you put the
knight to e6 before being pushed
yeah it's it's just not good okay yeah
basically yes that's like a way to put
more pressure once you've already gotten
some pieces out exactly okay makes sense
and uh then you can involve your queen
you'll get the hang of these positions
pretty quickly but
if you know these main moves you'll
you'll be good perfect so i'll stick to
these variations then
right and uh we'll definitely play some
play some practice games in these in
these positions yeah and i'm going to
save them and
review them too because i need to stakes
are high i need to start learning all of
these
because in bullet right you have to know
things by heart it's not enough
it's just if you know things by heart
and then you play by your intuition it
helps so much
right and one future session we'll just
all we'll do is just like play these
problematic
openings and talk about it that you're a
thousand points
higher rated than me in a bullet that's
insane
holy crap well once you reach 2500 it'll
only be
yeah exactly because i'll i'll be
gaining
so did you save the pgm can we yeah i
saved it perfect
so um that's the classical variation
that's most most of what's played
against you
um so so maybe then we could just let me
save this again
um and rename it as classical and then
we could do a new pgm just so i don't
get it
sure okay so i i don't want to bore you
to death with opening so maybe we can do
one more line and then very helpful uh
dania this is extremely helpful thank
you for doing this yeah i
of course of course and anybody in the
chat was like thought you know this is
oh yeah this is crucial work i don't
want to bore you for your chat
no no no no i'm i'm saying this is like
i think everybody understands this is
crucial work and
the people who just shirk openings for
their whole life you know unfortunately
you know you have to pay the price for
it at some point and i've been one of
those people but
okay so the how concerning is the french
for you and is there something within
the french that
that that concerns you with white with
uh
yeah actually and i i'm just gonna ask
quickly
about the lines that i looked through
today so i think
advanced line if i had some tips on that
um and then
honestly i know theory here and this is
somewhere where you could help me
because it's not like i don't know the
lines
i just i just find them so hard to play
uh in bullet yes so they are
um and then here a6 and i play the queen
b5 line and even in stuff like this
i find it so hard to play these as black
and bullet these kinds of close
positions where sometimes you have to
castle queenside
other times you castle kingside and and
g4 f5 and bullet is just terrifying
right so there's two options we can
definitely
look into this and and make some
refinements but andrew tang
you know has made a career out of
playing have you ever played de4
and i know this is a bad reputation but
it's actually an
amazing bullet opening would you
consider it or do would you prefer just
absolutely absolutely i just loaded the
line
i just promoted the line and i'm
deleting the entire side
and what makes this really good and i've
struggled against the e4 my whole life
what makes this really good is it has a
reputation as a really passive line not
dangerous
white usually plays the same setup in
bullet every game
it's very easy to fall asleep and get
into a really bad position really fast
and that's basically what i've done many
many times so
have you i assume you've seen this
before and you know that knight d7 is is
the main follow-up
yep okay one sec i've opened
like i have actually looked at this line
a little bit before but a long time ago
okay so almost everybody and i'm gonna
i'm just opening up my notes on chess
piece just give me a second
almost everybody plays the same setup
for white they play knight f3
and well what do you think you do here
it's super intuitive
usually i play either knight f6 or
bishop b7 knight f6 yeah and develop
your knights
people take you take back
now almost everybody plays bishop d3 uh
there's a million moves here
your responses are going to be the same
but in my experience most people do this
now you play c5
yep that's what i was going to arrow
so the most popular and once again we'll
start with the setup that i find people
doing all the time
it's d take c5 although they don't have
to do that of course you take
yep okay they they either castle yeah
they usually castle
and so do you um are there any ever
tricks with like bishop b5 you just play
bishop e7 right this should be five
bishop d7 yeah i know you're
open position you're good i mean this is
already so much easier to play than the
other line of course i do like the fact
that white has pressure on this knight
so you don't play anything like bishop
seven that would be weird
no so there's only like one or two
interesting things you have to you have
to know here and the move is b6
the move is b6 now your goal is to play
bishop b7 you've got beautiful bishops
and here's the key rule you are usually
not worried about moving your queen away
from the pin even though they can play
bishop
f6 gf that is going to be good for black
because you're going to move your king
away and use the g file and make them
okay um now some people go bishop before
here that's
actually hacks this is going to be
i think you're gonna enjoy the system
because it's you play the same moves
against everything and
people struggle against it so bishop
before is the blunder can you tell me
why
um because you take the queen and then
take the bishop
you take the queen and take the bishop
so the main move everybody plays queen
e2
now you continue developing naturally
okay so bishop b7 yeah okay d1 and here
whoops sorry okay d1 and here apply the
rule that we just discussed and try to
find
where you would put the queen yeah queen
c7
supernatural now bishop takes f6 you can
correct me if i'm wrong i think a lot of
people are going to just immediately
take
yeah i think they'd be very tempted to
just take and i don't know
and bishop before is the main move here
which leads to
a position where black is on comfortable
side of equality
um i don't know how else people might
play knight d2
um what do you feel like is reasonable
here what do you think we might expect
from people
um so i think this the scarier idea is
queen d2 just because as soon as people
see check they tend to go for it
right so king g7 here oh knight d2 or
queen d2
uh knight d2 i was thinking okay
so if knight d2 you need to intercept
the light squared bishop by playing f5
okay right because if i play king h5
is that not hey you can play but they
can i think they might be able to force
like a perpetual
that's like right okay so let me check
so
so the rule here will be just to push f5
right away king and trade is good too
but yeah f5 is great
if they play knight d2 and if they play
queen h5
then um king h8 is good yeah and rogue
g8
and you can make them pretty closely
this looks very comfortable
right it is and they if they're good
they'll find a way to trade the bishops
but
you'll be left with the bishop against
tonight which is pretty easy to play
okay so the main move and really the
only way to equalize right is bishop b4
and um if you try this system out we'll
see what people actually play
um so you play rook rook fd8 here
they take on b7 then queen takes b7 and
here's the thing if white tries to like
trade everything off the board they're
going to be worse
um so it takes takes if they try this
right yeah
you take and now can you centralize your
queen i mean
i guess i don't play queen d5 i like
queen e4 because i want
to keep pressure on c2 the knight is
kind of tied in
my king has escaped squares this is much
nicer to play as black and bullet
and by this point you've played quickly
they've spent like 20 seconds
and you've got a million improving moves
as you said f5 b5
tactics along the diagonal um this is
likely to arise
um against some people this particular
position actually
so okay uh that's that's like the most
we went down the most popular route
which is not white's best line of course
um if white knows what to do but um
yeah okay how is this looking so far
this is looking really good so far
good good bullet line stop me if you're
not feeling comfortable i'm like
i'm not i will not be offended that like
so bishop f4 you also go
out my line to this okay perfect
and your bottom line is going to be you
you have to exercise your your judgment
so you're not literally going to play c5
against absolutely everything the only
other move i wanted to talk about right
now
because we also want to take a quick
look at the advance is uh
so bishop g5 is possible in this
position i think some people might play
i have seen bishop g5 as well and i
usually play bishop e7 which i don't
think is a good idea anymore
um maybe not as necessary you actually
can play c5 here you can play let me see
h6 is a move
let me see what the good people do in
this position bishop g5 is not that
common
and the yeah so h6 is a good move
h6 bishop h4 c5 just get the bishop out
of the picture and then go c5
okay most people will check why do you
have to get the bishop out of the
picture first what was the difference in
bishop on g5 um
well it's a good idea to have in your
pocket the move g5
okay so and and also just the lifts for
when you castle short i think it's just
later pretty significant improvement now
bishop b5 you're not afraid of you just
go bishop d7
takes queen takes and you might get the
same structure this structure is almost
always going to be good for black
okay so in this position
um it's kind of similar to the other one
except for i have h6 so let's say he
takes
and i take back and
it is there a situation where queens are
on the ball are on the board and if
that's the case do i castle queenside or
kingside i would castle queenside and
also i would add that you can play queen
c6 here
you can keep the queens on the board
play rook d8 with tempo and pick the
pawn off with your bishop and you can
even
keep your king on f8 or in the center
white doesn't have the firepower really
to do anything to it
okay okay so
yeah and i will say that there's a
couple of systems here
that are a little bit annoying there's
g3 for example which i myself play with
white
but black and equalized here um and my
proposal would be that you tried this in
a couple of games it's not like you're
going to get blown off the board already
you know the main moves and we see what
people end up playing most of the time
okay so unless you want to you want to
take a look at some of these other lines
no no i think i think this is okay so so
with g3 were you just saying that you
don't go for c5
so yeah the point of g3 is that it's
aimed against um
against c5 so the the most reliable line
here is just to play one second let me
see
it's just to play bishop d7 why is this
aimed against c5 because if you play c5
you're gonna run into a situation c5 is
not terrible it's been played many times
you're gonna run into a situation where
it's hard to develop the bishop
basically and and you're opening up the
the bishop with tempo
exactly exactly now c5 has been played
by many gm's and it's
it's not bad but white is slightly
better there so there's a cool line
where you play bishop d7 now if black
plays
sorry if white plays bishop g2 what do
you think you do here what's the
follow-up to bishop
variation one second sure okay so uh
bishop d7 and you were saying what was
your question
okay so if you shoot g2
what would i play here okay so so c5 i'm
i almost
don't want to do anymore um bishop c6 is
interesting that's correct just contest
white's bishop
and the other bishop goes to d6 you
castle i mean it is kind of implied if
bishop d7
was the right move right and and this
equalizes this was played by the
specialist of the line georg meyer
now white sometimes goes 95 yeah he's
and i hate him
tired of the french but he plays this
all the time and i would roll my eyes
every time which is why you would play
it of course because people hate facing
this
yeah now here you go bishop c6 and after
knight c6 you have queen d5 that's the
point of the line actually
oh that's nice this is very cute
yeah meyer played this four times four
out of five times this position arose
was a meyer game
he's a specialist for a reason right
yeah he's he finds all these little
crazy tricks here and so black is
completely fine here bishop dc you know
white can't castle short so
for a bullet perspective this is a good
position yeah no this is great
okay this is good um should i save it
here
sure and if you want we can also look at
the advance and then you can save it or
uh i'm just going to save the the
different variations that's okay
um
classical fringe okay
and then the advanced would be great too
um because i i get the advanced so often
in
bullet and it's another one that i've
looked up theory but i think just
pushing me towards the right line would
make a difference so i have a cool line
against the advanced that you can
consider
so let's just go for the cool line
because i already know that mine i've
looked
at theory and even the lines that are
supposed to be okay i don't enjoy
it perfect so let me pull up my file i
have a file on this
uh french advance h6 black okay
this is a couple of years old but i you
know it's still pretty decent
okay for me a couple of years old is
good
so good to hear it's here so c3 you came
to the lesson you don't even have fresh
theory that's actually
horrible i'm i'm getting worse and worse
i'm degrading
so knight c6 nine of three now ui soon
play queen v6
i should play queen b6 i usually go c
takes d4
knight e7 and knight f5 and yeah i've
also i've also looked at the queen b6
line
so the line that i'm recommending to is
knight h6
oh okay that's a sideline and it's a
it's dangerous
if white doesn't know what to do because
here's the thing um
oh wait wait um do you mind if i just
reset it so that my
files
and promote variation sorry i'm just
cleaning it
okay as long as you need no problem all
right so here
um see four three
knight two six and then end of three
yeah knight h6 and the idea is obviously
to put the knight on f5 now
uh most people i assume will play the
way that they would play
against queen b6 so either a3 or bishop
d3
and no taking on h6 is bad right taking
on h6 so if they take on h6
you take and um yeah it's not that bad
but it's very risky
because you're going to go bishop g7
castle quickly f6
and you're going to get massive play on
the on the king side so to be specific
uh bishop e2 is the main move
uh then you go bishop g7 and i know the
bishop looks bad but you are eventually
going to go f6
castles castles okay so you do castle
yolo
exactly and uh after knight bd2 the move
in my file is actually queen b6
queen b6 interesting so you
gave away your knight on h6 and you are
putting pressure on b2 you're missing a
c1 bishop
but what if you just play something
normal like rook b1
he gives up the pawn so you're
threatening the pawn
so you have to play knight p3 almost
well then you win the other pond
white's gonna why it's not gonna survive
here for very long and this is not a
true my queen is not getting trapped it
has an escape route oh
then you want to play f6 at the right
moment okay wait wait wait so
so what is white supposed to do here
white's supposed to go queen b3 not an
easy move to find a bullet
and then you just keep the tension of
the bishop d7
all right uh now oops sorry roll call
for just a second what were you saying
uh i was just promoting the variation so
one like
sideline advice that i would have and
this is maybe too general but
these moves that keep the tension like
bishop d7 um you want to make yourself
this world and if like if you don't know
what to do
it's best like to have a supply of these
moves like rook c1 rookie 8
um you know try to practice making those
moves quickly if you're not sure what to
do because
sometimes you just want to keep the
tension and you want your opponent to be
the first to flinch you don't always
have to like
be the one to open up the position or
have a plan plenty of times i don't have
a plan i literally just play king h1
king g1 there's no shame in that
okay let them be the one to you know
waste a bunch of time searching for a
plan
in these kinds of positions for sure so
bishop d7 is good
and black is slightly better and then
what if white just keeps the tension
okay let's do that it is hard to find
moves for white here
it is i don't i don't want to take and
where are my pieces going so no you know
what this is enough this line looks bad
we can go back i don't think you're
gonna take
on eight okay yeah so and we'll look at
bishop h6 and bishop d3l so knight h6
i'm anticipating that people will play
the same way they do after queen b6 so
let's start with a3
because that is as you know the main
move against queen b6
and people just have to copy curious why
you like knight h6 but 97 was a bad line
well i think 97 no probably 97 is a way
of doing it but
i think knight h6 allows for f6 whereas
97
f6 you sever the connection between the
queen and the f6 square
so do you go for f6 right away here in
in certain positions i'm just looking up
what i
so there is a let me just say you can
play either knight f5 or f6 i marked f6
as interesting
it depends what level of craziness you
want in the position better for bullet
um let me see let me see how the 95 line
goes
i love how you just have these files
well
i i prepared the french for like the
2016 us championship so
um so okay i i would say you're probably
going to be more comfortable with knight
f5
okay but i got blasted by fabian
20 moves despite halls yeah i mean he
was world number two so it does happen
dania
i want from time to time so b4 is how
everybody plays this
now one very important conceptual
there's also the bishop d3
bishop eighth idea that is a great
structure for black
and bullet because i get this structure
very often
even in my [ __ ] oh amazing line because
everybody is tempted to go for this so
they actually play this line
almost 80 percent of the time that i get
in the advance so this is a position i
often
have and then i do struggle with a
little bit um
because i go for things like bishop e6
h6 e7 sometimes g5
definitely g5 but then i get kind of
in trouble on the green side okay so
let's let's do this step by step so cd4
let me just make sure i'm telling you
the right stuff here
so bishop d3 uh cd bishop f5 ed
so cd bishop b7 is good yes or bishop e6
but i like starting with bishop b7 too
cover the g5 square yep this is how i
play it too and then normally they
castle
okay oh they castle immediately okay
great now g5 is already an advantage for
black by the way
interesting and which is good because
this is the line i play and then i
usually get met by something like
e4 okay so let me just see if i analyze
this
so before you want to go um bishop e6 is
good or you can go f4
i mean i think for a bullet f4 is the
best so basically you don't need to play
ac
um you can but you don't need to because
b5 is met with knight a5
and you're totally fine but a6 is also
fine
um and the way that they have to respond
to a6 is
quite difficult but f4 is good okay and
let's say knight c3 trying to come first
something like this
okay so um the point here for black
is that you're going to combine these
moves with just regular development you
don't have to go crazy on the kids you
don't have to go nuts and push
no you actually can castle to that side
and go king h8
and knight a4 is met with and
prophylaxis is super effective in
bullets so what do you think you do here
so you said prophylaxis with which makes
me think i'm just posit
improving the position of my pieces
otherwise i would have been tempted to
push b6 no you're correct that is what
it is
oh okay b6 is right stopping their idea
and why does no moves like um
bishop b2 i guess yeah i guess you have
to play bishop b3 you're bringing your
rook
now again you play slowly and you
improve your position to the maximum
queen d7 rook c8 castle king h8
you don't actually ever and and this is
also very effective in bullet
because they never know when you're
going to play g4 so they're constantly
on the edge
yeah it's like the guillotine above
their head you know it's going to drop
at some point they're afraid
right exactly so black is just much
better
here um and you can play moves fast qd7
castle rook c8 bishop f5 queen e6
and uh white is just worse i think i've
just gone
crazy in these lines generally and
that's why yeah
yeah because then you have to calculate
if you go like g4 g3 too early your king
ends up being weak
so normally you actually do want to cast
on goku h8 here
castle and king h8 okay and rogue g8
maybe to even make g4 stronger if you do
go crazy at some point right
right uh i'm just gonna do this for the
line
so i can't save the arrows i i know it's
silly but you know what i mean how
interest space you usually have those
okay perfect
um okay so that makes sense so this is a
bad line if they do castle
yes they shouldn't castle that early
okay so so if they take i'm good
if they don't take um
so if i play knight e5 and they push b4
then
so then there's a cool line you take on
d4
and first you go bishop d7 the reason
you develop your queen side first
is you want the potential to play rook c
you also have a really cool shot
so so um if they go bishop b2
you have the very strong move b5 and
if there's actually a simple tactical
idea what is what is it
um i don't like that you said simple uh
i'm just kidding
okay so so let's see so what would i
look at knight takes knight takes
queen here bishop takes those are the
options uh anything
else any other captures by the knight
and e5 yeah exactly so that's what it is
and in general right
you can't capture elsewhere because
white's going to take with chuck
yeah yeah and then what's going to take
the knight so
so white black's already better here
bishop d6 castle you've got the c4
square et cetera
so he can't take on v5 then he can't
take on b5
um so the main move is is knight c3 and
you fall
the kind of thing that can be annoying
oh you can't do it anymore though so
never mind
oh which wait you mean bishop b5 no no i
i i was tripping um so you push e5 you
don't go a6 here
nope you push a5 interesting because i
would often play a6 here
so i don't think i've ever pushed a5
i've always done a6 so this is a big
discovery for me this isn't a beautiful
moment for me yeah well it's a pretty
unique position it's i don't know if
we've transposed into something
theoretical or you're just saying in
general
uh just in general i haven't thought of
you could play a6 i mean it's solid
and no but she'll be a5 show me five
okay so a5
um what do you think white will do here
um so b5 is hanging
and now it would be defended although b4
is also hanging so it's pretty messy but
obviously we have to look at both of the
captures because otherwise
then this pawn is under attack and you
have to play something like 92 or queen
b3
right which is pretty passive you'll
just take anyway
right right so i imagine taking on b5 is
the sharpest line but it's really simple
you just take and and essentially you're
going to attack them on the queen side
their pawn on d4 is super weak
um you're going to castle you're going
to go queen b6 it's super easy play
their bishop is really bad
this really solves the advanced
variation with how people my level play
bullet honestly
yeah knight h6 is a very dangerous i
played myself in bullets so it's like i
everything that i've shown you i
actually play so i i appreciate you
bringing out the goods dania
no i'm happy to more than happy to and
it you know this line isn't like
completely unknown it's been played
um and and yeah so that's basically you
go bishop d7 then b5
and then a5 now what i would say is
don't worry too much about trying to
memorize remember every little move
if you're not sure just play the solid
mode like play a6 desperate for my hair
that i might just learn these
moves generally and then play them by
intuition
yeah that that would be the best now one
last thing yeah
in in the position where they played
knight c3 if they try knight sorry not
this one
but not this one but where was the other
line uh the one where they played a3
and b4 it takes takes bishop d7 which
should be 2b5
so in this position remind me how you
follow up
um so knight bd2
i just go a5 here yeah crucial because
otherwise don't let them get the knight
to c5
you need to attack the pawn and break it
down and now take with the knight so
that that knight can go where
so that now you go to c4 bingo
exactly you like me adding crucial in
the notes
i love it this is just professional file
right here exactly exactly these kinds
of files
they're beautiful this is awesome no
this is uh
you you know this is right up your alley
i think this if we can solve
your black openings and i think we've
we've gone a long way already then
exactly i think you'll see all my black
openings then i'm gonna stop tilting
half the time
and it's just gonna help so much it's
helps me so much okay let me let me save
this one also
okay i'm gonna rename it advanced
perfect okay yeah
i don't i don't really have as much
trouble with the other ones uh
can i just ask you really quickly about
how to play against um
a king's indian attack with the french
because you play it very well
so yeah king's indian attack is
definitely sharpest just if you have
some kind of variation you'd recommend
here
yeah so obviously like the main line is
like c5 knight c6
one very good setup also because it
transposes and a lot of people play
knight f3 or this line
i think the setup recommended to me by
my old coaches so you go c5
knight c6 and and now you go g6 and
you've probably seen this before
like 97 or knight f6 except and i've
played this
normally people go knight e7 but knight
f6 is actually very
underrated move here because if e5 you
have 97 and you win the pawn
that's what makes us so hard for white
to play so rookie one for example you
can castle they still lose their pawn if
they go e5
okay so you're keeping the tension which
is really annoying bullet
yeah exactly and if they go c3
um then you actually can take on e4 the
moment they go c3 you take on e4 and the
reason why
is that they weaken the d3 square okay
and here you go e5
you can go e5 yeah that's fine that's
good no it's it's it's equal it's equal
it's okay what would you recommend so
let me let me check actually
if you just give me a second i'm going
to i'm going to say if you have anything
when you say it's fine it gives me it
makes no no it's good it's good
um but let me just see so
here
cause i remember a game in this line
right just one moment
okay let's see so many people are are
really enjoying your lesson by the way
i'm glad to hear that um i am as well
this is
you know i'm happy that your openings
are going to get solved because that's
honestly like a hidden reason honestly
this is going to be so helpful because
even when i look at variations like i
looked at the advance that i was like
or no i looked at the classical and i
didn't even think about taking on
on e4 right
no that makes that makes a lot of sense
okay so
here ah so rookie one castles e5
i'm curious what you're gonna come up
with d takes details
what else would i do here so you can
play with knight g7 by the way that's
good but queen b6 here is interesting
sorry not d take c4 queen b6 in this
position oh so so you don't
wait wait you just told me to take as
soon as they first d3
it's all equal you can play queen b6 you
can take
it's honestly all it's all fine okay
um and one sec it's all fine
but i like queen b6 because a lot of
people will play five here and what's
wrong with that both
like e7 97 and if d4
uh sorry knight
well knight g7 and if d4
oh that's what you want to play knight g
for no uh that's why you
want to play queen b6 to prevent d4
because you can just take everything on
d4
oh true sorry first so for some reason i
thought there was a deeper tactic where
you take everything and you take on e5
and you trick your opponent into taking
and open no one has to do
you you basically want them to take on
d5 then you're gonna get a great
position
okay so okay that's that's what i would
say now a lot of people don't know to
play c3 they'll struggle
or they'll go knight f1 in this position
um which which is totally colorless i
mean here you can go queen c7 or you
could
you know you could even just win the
pawn white can get some compensation if
he's careful but not in bullet
okay this is perfect so this is what i
would recommend we can definitely work
on that more
oh the future i'm just going to save
this for the kings
definitely okay got it oh this is so
helpful this this solves my issues with
the friendship i'm glad to hear that and
what we should do is you know when
when you play you know get a couple of
games in each of these lines we'll
we'll go back and we'll review what
people have done and what you don't when
you did
it in response and will improve yeah no
this is perfect because my
my black openings are so bad that i'm
pretty sure even if i just learn
these oh i did have another question in
the king's indian i'm sorry we've done
so many uh so much opening theory it's
all good
this is what you need to do what what
was the other question that i had
what do you what would you suggest well
yeah would you say i play the same ish
what would you suggest against the same
ish because i don't like the c5 line and
bullet
and the knight d7 line is really awkward
okay so
should we can can i use this board or do
you want to make a new yeah
i'm just going to make a new one really
all right
so let's delve into the samish yes
there's like two lines that i'm that i
was debating over but have you seen
knight c6
um i have seen it occasionally yeah
okay so this is if they play d6 you go
back right
so you i i've noticed that you played d5
with white
but that's actually not a not not the
best because of knight e5
yeah i'm going to learn for our next
odds match
yeah i mean yeah because d595 black
starts
you go c6 and wait wait but and oh and
f4 doesn't work because you just play
here yeah yeah okay well f4 actually you
can yeah you play knight
g4 and a lot of people go here but
um basically white's position is already
falling apart you can go c5
okay and they have nothing to do with
the bishop
okay i'll just that's good enough for
this yeah now most people play knight g
to the main line
oh yeah makes sense or yeah or queen d2
i know the knight c6 a6 line hasn't i've
seen it before because i also play the
same ish but i haven't ever
played it as black so queen d2 is
inaccurate i think because of e5
d5 and now where does the knight go e4
yeah knight d4 and this is really
interesting
and after knight d4 if they take twice
do you know how to react
um my guess would there's a tactic
i assumed dania yeah you knew
um you'd never know there's a tactic
it's not like there's a discovered
attack
knight takes e4 takes rookie eight yeah
exactly 94 queen e48 yeah
so um and some people do fall into that
they just automatically take
now but almost everybody's gonna go
knight g2 you go a6 and they go queen d2
now here
there's a very tricky line where you go
knight a5 immediately thank you real mr
perry for the five gifted appreciate it
so knight a5
okay and i'm going to show you how
you're going to win a bunch of games
now most people play b3 and you play b5
people assume this is like a banco game
but you've done this to me
so many times yes
i'm never gonna fall for it again and
then we i forget we play again two
months after and what do i do
i fall into this again exactly so
i actually play this in classical chess
um again
this is my main line but knight takes me
there as you know is the idea the most
annoying tactic of all time
it's so annoying because you play the
moves on autopilot and bullet and then
you just fall into it
no it's it's really really hard because
when people don't see it they they
resort to their first instinct
the great thing is if they defend upon
in another way if they go knight g3
then then you go b5 and it's the same
the same thing right knight b3 is a
threat right because that's why you're
supposed to play knight c1 though right
right yeah exactly that knight c1 is the
main line
and now you go knight steps out to d7
several ideas
um you might play c5 but most of the
time you're gonna go e5 and quickly f5
so you're opening up the possibility for
f5 yeah okay
and uh if they go b4 again as as in many
lines of the king's indian you want to
provoke them into as many
of these pawn moves as possible because
a lot of people will do something like
this and after e5 black is already
better
i mean that's the nature of the king's
indian you have a5 and f5 and you just
have to play very energetically
and keep the pressure okay that makes
sense yeah and this isn't again i mean
so
you know i think there's a little
concern in my chat this is not you can
find my
game in this line in the database like
this is a legitimate attempt at equality
of course white can
play it perfectly and white can try to
get an edge but it's not easy
um and it's it's worth uh worth the
trick
in bullet because you're gonna
definitely win some games this way yeah
okay perfect
so i i'm just gonna save this pgn and
look at this line perfect this is better
than my nike seven stuff
yeah no 97 is past and it you can't let
white
do his main stuff with the g4 h4
yeah i like that you actually play this
opening as black juice
right it's it's very convenient yeah
yeah
yeah okay so so that's the same-ish um
do you yeah okay so i think i think you
you've given so much with the openings
it's
already extremely helpful okay so let's
pause the openings for now and we can do
white in the next session
yeah no this is perfect because i i want
to be able to review these it's already
so helpful
and now it's on me to just learn these
and i think it's already going to be
very
very much a lift in my bullet i
appreciate it and we you know
now i'm personally invested in this so
it's not a problem and
yeah are you so personally invested that
if i don't reach 2500 you'll also shave
your
head oh i don't know about that level of
personal investment but
wait wait but donna you think i'm really
gonna lose
no i mean oh so you're saying ah you
caught me there
you caught me there you don't believe in
me i
don't just believe in you i mean i
believe in you so much that not only
will i shave my head
if you okay the only reason
that i won't make a commitment is
because i am full of
i 100 believe you knew but i didn't
believe you i wouldn't be doing this
how about that i'll take it i'll take it
i know that's half-assed but you got it
it's okay chat he coached us he doesn't
have to believe in us
he doesn't have to put his hair on the
line it's not like you'd grow back
faster than ours
my hair does grow back pretty fast so
maybe i should put it on the line well
here's the thing
um i'll revisit this this question in a
couple of days when i see your progress
okay that sounds good as a ceasefire
okay sounds great thank you so much for
your time today i really appreciate it
um and i'm gonna make sure that i go
over these lines so that it was
you know a good use of your time i know
you're super busy of course it's it's
not a problem
and um so i assume you're just gonna
play some bullet
um um honestly i might end and put these
lines into chess space and just kind of
save them are you gonna keep streaming
i'm gonna keep streaming for a bit yeah
yeah and what we can do is
we can do some wide openings next time
and we can do some some practical drill
we can just play a bunch of games
with black okay and we'll play complete
games just so
you can you know get as much practice as
possible because that's going to be
crucial
it will but i definitely don't want to
practice bullet until i've actually
learned these lines kind of like doing
puzzles you want to understand it before
you do the speed
okay so let's let's make it a priority
to just play a bunch of games in these
lines next time
exactly so i'm gonna make sure that i
learn these and i have them memorized
and then if we could do some practice
games then i'll play more bullet and
i'll let you know where i'm at
perfect i'll i'll try to make myself
available asap but this was awesome
alexander i'm very very happy to help
him
thank you so much you will get 2500
you're you're
you're almost there and i i honestly
think the openings are the biggest thing
holding it back six is not almost there
but i do
three games against sicario or me and
you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly okay thank you so
much donya
of course my pleasure have a great night
we'll talk soon
okay bye
you